fini a poussé un gros coup de gueule
chez jean marc morandini c'était
geneviève de fontenay elle était
l'invitée de jean-marc morandini la
pousse un gros coup de gueule qui fait
beaucoup parler
elle était invitée pour réagir à l'appel
de laurent rookie de boycotter les miss
france mais surtout surtout en outre sur
un autre sujet qu'elle s'est étendu la
possibilité d'avoir une candidate
transgenres au concours et elle y est
allée très fort regarder ce n est jamais
j'aurais imaginé qu'on puisse accolé
transgenres amuseront parce que c'était
tellement contre nature de toute façon
rencontre nature baba bâ cissé comptent
remettre en jambe à celui qui qui qui
était à l'eurovision là le français a
aidé et étrangers avaient atteint vu sa
réussite à bord mais c'est pas la
question de qui ça vous parle de bilal
assadi
non il est pas transgenres bilal assadi
bien c'est dit c'est un homme c'est
pendant ces baby là c'était un garçon
qui était déguisé en voilà mais c'est
plus début c'était une fille bon bah
c'est quelque chose de pas normal comme
des analyses ont toutes les deux
systèmes mixtes l'ancien la journée un
point
ouais merci mais je vous le retire
direct qu'est ce que vous avez à barvaux
l'ennemi est complètement largué c'est
vrai que geneviève alors là aussi
fracassé voilà je vous le dis au long au
pied regardez est là elle avait appelé
au boycott des miss france qui sera un
concours ang est un gars est sexiste
regarder jouer plutôt sur 121 les
batteries babin au revoir au roi marine
d'orphelins qui faisait sa médecine et
tout s'est jamais été des bacs et chic
qu'est ce que vous répondez alors en mai
prévu ce qui fait de ce en rayon à lui
et pas ceux qui paie dont on ne supprime
pas une miss france maintenant qui
existe depuis 100 ans ça vous énerve ça
qui les étreint sur rue qui ferait mieux
de s'occuper de son rayon 1 voilà
d'accord se sont fiés aux absences de
rio parce qu'elle est harcelée par un
superbe
et c'est passante en miss france evans
et 1927 merci merci on n'avait pas pensé
vous rappellera milieu de semaine
prochaine